好，來，我們繼續，我們繼續。同樣在這本講義的第13頁，第13頁。
好，我們來看這個 n 喔，n，在台語字是 n 喔，na，那，藍色的藍，或是籃子的籃，n-a-na，第五調，第五調。
再來 n-e-ne，ne，我們說呢啦，這樣、這樣，這個腔調不同。
再來 ni，藍色的藍，ni，ni。還有這字，另外一個音叫做 ni，五點的點，五點的點。
好，再來下面，n-o-no，no，這個長老叫做 tióng-nóo，tióng-nóo，no。
再來下面，蛋，這個華語的蛋，讀作 nn̄g，第七調，nn̄g，第七調。所以它的調有 w 的標在 ng 的 n 上面，ng 的 n 上面。
好，再來 l-a-la，la，這字 la。l-e-le，le，是第二調的 le，失禮的禮。
再來 l-i-li，li，第二調，li，li，我們那個什麼里，里民的里。再來 l-oo-lôo，lôo，lôo，這個不是姓，姓是 lû，lôo，lôo。
再來囉唆的囉，口字旁，lô，口字旁還有一個囉，lô。再來 l-o-lo，lo，lo，和那個滷肉的滷一樣，不過字不同，自己看，lo。
再來 l-u-lû，仙女，也有人說仙女，腔調不同，仙女，仙女。再來 k-a-ka，ka，加油的加，加油的加。
說到加油，我們華語所說去加油站加油，去加油站加油，我們台語要怎麼說？
加油、加油、加油，我們台語比較正統的說法是什麼？添油。有聽過嗎？我爸都說，我要去添油，我要去加油站添油。
添，三點水加上一個真，添，華語的添，添油，添，用添的，油用添的。這樣我們台語說加油是什麼？鼓勵加油，叫做加油。
我們會說，這次考試要加油喔，不是叫你去加油站加油，是你愛加油。所以我們如果說去加那個燃料，我們會說添油，添油。
再來下面 ke，同樣，加減的加，我們會說 ke，所以加減我們唸作 ke-kiám。所以你看一個字就有兩個音，一個唸作 ka，一個唸作 ke。
多說的，多說。以前我們上班的時候，啊你多說的，多說，多說的，多說。再來 k-i-ki，這個基，基本的基，開基，開基，我們台灣很多，台南那邊，古城很多開基，開基祖啦，他們那個廟宇的廟，開基廟，基。
再來 k-oo-kô，kô，什麼 kô，什麼按，什麼 kô 什麼 kô 的 kô。再來 k-o-ko，這都知道，阿姑的姑，阿姑、香菇、冬菇也是，香菇的姑。
我們台語有一個，教你無心，做這個要食菇，香菇的姑，要食菇，意思就是說無意義。再來 k-u-ku，ku。
所以我們華語說烏龜，我們台語說一個字就好，龜。我們華語的烏龜就是台語的龜。你不要兩個字照唸，你如果兩個字照唸叫做烏龜，烏龜的烏，烏龜，烏龜就是那個拉皮條的，烏龜。
再來 k-ng-kng，kng，光明的光，kng，kng，k-ng，唸作 ng 喔，k-ng-kng，kng，光，光明的光。那個摃，提手旁加上一個工，也是唸作 kòng，摃球的摃。
再來 kh-a-kha，這個第二調，kha，吃巧不吃飽，吃巧不吃飽，kh-a-kha。這字巧，還有另外一個同音，叫做 khiáu，聰明就是這字，叫做 khiáu，就是這字巧。
再來 kh-e-khe，第一調 khe，這都知道。所以我們說，都是別人的錯，嫌東嫌西，不會開船嫌溪彎。
不會開船嫌溪彎。再來 kh-i-khì，欺騙的欺，起，早起的起。kh-oo-khô，這大家都知道，苦，哪一苦。再來 kh-o-khó，khó，第二調 khó，khó。
救苦的苦。再來 kh-u-khu，這都知道，第一調 khu。再來下面，米糠的糠，kh-ng-khng，khng，米糠的糠。
再來後面，g，濁音，g-a-gâ，第五調 gâ，gâ。gâ 是什麼你知道嗎？螺絲，螺絲那個紋，螺絲鉸，螺絲鉸。
他們黑手都說，那個螺紋如果磨損的，就 bak-gâ，螺絲 bak-gâ。bak-gâ 是日語。他們黑手界很多都用這字，用這字。所以我們用台羅拼音才有辦法拼出那個音，漢字不一定寫得出來。
就像說那個螺絲起子，他們都用台羅，都用台羅拼音，他們有一些工具都用這字。再來第二組，g-e-gê，gê，gê，第七調 gê，藝術的藝。
你如果唸作 gê-sut 就變成第三調，gê，gê。再來 g-i-gî，gî，gî，所以宜蘭我們唸作 Gî-lân，Gî-lân。所以華語很多義、宜，會唸作 g-i-gî，Gî-lân，都唸 Gî-lân。
再來 g-oo-gô，gô，海邊，我們中部海邊他們會唸作什麼？giâ。我以前同事，他們家住在那個梧棲那邊，我要去他們家，他母親說，你要吃鵝嗎？
聽不懂，我聽不懂。原來他們那個鵝肉，鵝肉。我才知道他們那邊鵝說 giâ，鵝肉。再來，g-o-gô，gô，gô，第七調 gô，gô-pê-gô。
再來 g-u-gû，這都知道，第五調 gû。再來第三種濁音，ng，ng，ng-a-ngá，雅，優雅的雅，ngá-ngá。我們台中北邊那個叫做大雅。
它變成 n-g-e-2，第二調，ngé。再來 ng-e，ngē，ngē，它是第七調，ngē。ngē 是什麼？困難的、不好做的叫做 ngē。
你都挑軟的，我都吃硬的。你專挑軟柿子，不好的、困難的就留給我。我都吃硬的，你都吃軟的。所以軟的就寫作軟。
這都是我們台語的一種藝術，我們台語很有藝術，軟的、硬的。你如果是華語人就聽不懂，這是什麼？可以吃嗎？他是在形容事情。
你都挑軟的，我都吃硬的。再來下面，ng-i-ngî，同樣，它是不同腔口，我們說 ngē 說 ngî，ngî。下面這個我，ng-oo-ngóo，ngóo。
〔此段辨識失敗〕
好，啊
再來，啊
中，資、庸、中，中、中、中
那個宋中的中，中
吃
我們每天都在吃的，吃啊，吃
吃、昂、倉，穀倉的倉，倉，好
吃、英、清，清，好
所以，我們說吃的清淡
我們台語很少說淡
說吃得很清，吃得很清
就是吃的清淡
好，再來，吃、翁、蔥，聰明的聰，好
吃、一、昂、強，第四聲喔
吃、一、昂、強，強
沖水，沖水
我們說，啊，去，去廁所要沖水，好
這個強字，我們台語有一個我們比較常聽到的
瀑布，瀑布
水強（瀑布）
所以沖水倒過來，叫做水強
水強，就是瀑布啦
水強
水強，沖水，不是沖水
因為那個水的力道很大，所以用強
我站在瀑布的下面，沖水
水強，沖水，沖水是動詞，水強是名詞，瀑布
好，下面還有一個 I-O-N-G 喔
吃、用、衝，衝，也是這個衝字
是什麼？路沖的沖
看風水的路沖，這個沖字，中中的中
路沖的沖
還有那個衝突的衝，也是同音
衝撞的衝，也是同音
有的那個手字旁的衝，衝、衝、衝、衝
所以這個衝字，行中間加一個虫
這個衝字，我們如果說闖紅燈，我們會說衝紅燈
你不要去闖紅燈，闖的那字人字旁加一個弄
不要去闖紅燈，衝的，好
再來，思，思、安、三，輕鬆的三，好
思、英、生，人生的生，思、翁、爽，爽，真爽的爽，好
思、一、昂、箱，那個箱，一箱兩箱的箱
再來，思、一、用、傷，傷
受傷的傷，還有
很嚴重
這次車禍呢，他受傷得很嚴重
傷重，傷重
傷重
這次車禍，受傷得很嚴重
受傷，受傷，我們華語說受傷，我們說受傷
受傷，受傷，我們現在都說受傷、受傷，其實台語是說受傷
受傷，受傷
那個傷，傷，還有一個叫做傷（太）
傷，傷
所以這個字，這個傷重，就是很嚴重，好，我們唸另一個音
思、一、用、傷
太重，傷重，同字，不同音，不同意思
這東西太重，我搬不動
我不要，太重，同樣是這個傷字，唸作傷（太）
所以我們台文至少這個字都有兩個音
你看，重、重，太重、傷重
我兩手搬一個太重的，受傷得很嚴重
所以你可以用這個台文開始造句
你去想想看它要怎麼發音，你就知道它的意思，你就可以自我造句
好，我們看下面這個日，日
日來加 I-A-N-G 呢，日、一、昂、樣，樣
樣
應用樣的樣，這個樣字有人也唸作樣
樣、樣
這個日字，說到這個日字，我們在，我台中人，正港台中人
日，這個日字，有時候都會音變，變成 G，G，G，G
應用樣，樣，我們都會說成樣
樣、樣，變成 G，G，台中一些音
都這樣，就像說那個棒球
它的聲母是日，日、一、歐、饒、饒，它是第七聲
我們台中如果說棒球，都會聽他講棒球
它的聲母變成 G
台中人，還有這腔，這聲母這款腔在南投也聽得到
南投我也在埔里聽過
我們台中跟南投的它的這聲母有的沒差別
日，有的日，他都會唸聲母的日，都唸作 G，G
樣、樣，應用樣
這樣講應用樣，其實它到底是啥？樣，還有樣，再來，茸，鹿茸的茸，茸
日、一、翁、茸、茸，第八聲喔，茸
我們過那個母親節，那個
代表母親節的那種花，我們說千日紅花
千日紅花，千，千日紅花
千日紅花，千
它開出來的花，像鹿茸那樣，千日紅花
好，後面這第十九頁這裡，入聲，入聲教過，看過
好，入聲教過，我們也是入聲跟這 NG 這裡，我覺得比較重要，它的發音，它的發音的時候，好
我們來看十九頁這裡，入聲母的，還有 AP，AP 唸作 ap
一盒兩盒的盒，再來，AT，at，at，這 at，壓轉的壓，還有那個壓
壓，再來 AK，ak，壓龜的壓
AH，ah，牛母魚的 ah，再來，ip，這 ip 是什麼？提手旁加一個意，那個揖網仔
飛龍的是，揖網仔，那個網仔我們在，在那個
後面花生底也是，它上面，它底那個
一張一張，叫做揖網仔
揖網，還有也說那個過網仔，也說底網仔
一張一張，這樣墊在那裡，好
也說過網仔
嘿，對對對，都有，好，再來 it，一二三四的一，再來 ik，這利益的益，好
IH 沒有，再來 UT，ut，熨斗的熨
好，下面我們來看一個有聲母的
PAP 沒有，PAT，pat，有 pat，它是第八聲喔，PAT，pat，pat
我們都沒有第八聲，我們都唸作 pat，其實它本調叫做 pat
一二三四五六七八，八，八，那個八直
八直有在，八直有在，也有人這樣講，這樣講三八三八這樣，八直
八直，再來這 pak，pak，那個剝削的削，剝啦，剝
剝皮 pak，這字另一個叫做 pe̍h，剝皮，那是白話音，剝皮要 pe̍h-puê，這字是 pak，剝削
剝削的削，剝削，再來一百兩百的百，百，百
還有那個大百的百，大百，大鈔
我們說大鈔我們說大百，大百，如果是零錢，我們說零星，零星，零零星星的零星，零星
零星，零星
所以有時你讀讀看，那個用華語唸跟用台語唸，意思真的有時候那個意思感覺
感覺比較老，你說那個人壽公司，南山，南山人壽南山的，還有一本
人生
零星，就是一些零錢啦，零錢，嘿，有一本雜誌有一本雜誌
華語唸，很
正常，實力對吧？
我們台語就很順暢喔
這本十全食美
就是很嚴重，食力
吃力，我們朋友也吃力，吃力
其實他要唸普通音也可以，叫做食力，食力
再來看看，這個筆，鉛筆的筆，這都知道，筆
再來，逼，逼迫的逼，逼
再來，鼻，鼻，鼻，鼻涕的鼻，鼻
鼻有一個形容詞叫做鼻鼻
不乾脆，做事情拖泥帶水
再來，不，不定義的不，意思不原因嘛，不，不定義的不
ph，ph，這個覆，覆蓋的覆，ph，覆
這個覆是什麼？覆載的覆，覆載的覆就是這個，覆蓋的覆這個覆，覆載
覆載大家都聽過
再來，ph-a-pha，剛才講的，打字的打，打字的打
再來，鼻，鼻，鼻涕的鼻，鼻
再來，ph-e-phe，撇，撇，文言文也是這個撇，撇
再來，ph-i-phi，譬，譬相，譬相就是譏笑，還加上那個揶揄啦
譬相很難聽的，譬
再來這個捔，捔就是拿刀揮，用揮動的去砍，叫做捔
砍草啦，或是說這個砍柴火啦，捔，動作比較快，力道比較大，捔
m，m-a-h，嘛，嘛，嘛
這個喔，是放在語尾，你也跟我講一個嘛，嘛
再來這個物，物，這個食物，好食物，好吃的東西，食物，食物，我們也講食物，也講食物，物
再來，b-a-t，密
這個是什麼？密密
這個密，密密，密
這個密，密密
再來，木，b-a-k，木，這個做木，就是木工、木匠，木
再來，肉，肉，這都知道
味，香味的味，味
再來，妙，妙，這個是那個幽默，我們也叫做幽妙，幽妙
再來，避，寫作避見，就是躲起來的意思
避見，不讓人看到避見，叫做避，避相揣，避相揣，捉迷藏，避相揣
揣是提手旁，揣
揣，揣，避，躲起來
再來，t，t-a-p，答，回答的答
t-a-t，踏，踏
有人名啦，還有那個踏到，如果你要說踏到，踏到，踏到地，踏
再來，塔，這個塔就是塔婆，塔婆的塔，塔
t-a-h，t-a-h，塔，塔，塔，塔
這個唸作塔，塔，塔
再來，直直的直，直，直，直直的直
再來，敵人的敵，敵，敵，無敵的敵
t-i-h，值，值
再來，t-u-t，突，突
有一個唐突，唐突的突
th，t-h-a-p，t-h-a-p，塔，塔，填空叫做塔空
塔空，填空，就像說我們那個考卷，填空，會寫作塔空
塔空，填空
這個塔，凹下去的凹，叫做塔，就像說那個臉龐，凹陷，眼眶凹陷，凹陷
再來，t-h-a-t，踏，這個踏都知道，用腳踏
再來，t-h-a-k，t-h-a-k，讀冊的讀，所以讀書，我們會用作不是用書，用冊，冊子的冊，讀書
再來，塔，這個塔都知道，水塔的塔
再來這個
t-h-i，t-h-i，剔，剃頭的剔，日字旁的一個剔，月，月還有一個剔部，叫做剃頭
剃頭就兩個意思，一個是玩耍，一個是在江湖上跟人家混
再來，t-h-e-k，剔，所以排斥的我們講排剔，排剔，排列的排，排斥一樣，寫作那個剔，排剔
再來，剔，這個剔都知道
再來，t-h-u-t，u-t唸作ut，t-h-ut，thut，thut-thâu，thut-thâu，禿頭
再來，後面，n，n-a，那，那，閃那，閃那是什麼？閃電，華語的閃電，閃那的那，寫作這個那
還有那個，那日
那日是什麼？那日就是像我們現在開始入秋，那個太陽，沒出來的時間越來越短
那日就是太陽出來一下下，叫做那日
再來，n-i-h，呢，呢跤尾的呢，墊腳尖，墊腳尖，叫做呢跤尾的呢，這個呢
還有竹字旁改成木字旁，同樣也是唸作呢，就是眨眼的眨，眨眼睛
呢，目一個呢，就是它的部首，它的這個字邊改成目
l，l-a-p，納，納稅金的納
再來，l-a-t，力，力，它是第八調，力，力草的力，力草就是力量、力道
l-a-k，六，也是同樣第八調，六，這個三四五六的六，我們都沒有第八調，我們都唸作五六，它是第八調，六
再來，喇叭的喇，喇，l-a-h，喇
再來，立正的立，l-i-p，l-ip，立
再來，暱稱的暱，暱，i-t唸作it嘛，l-it，暱，暱
再來，力量的力，l-ek，它是第八調，力，力
所以一個字就有兩個音，力也一個叫做la̍t，一個叫做li̍k
再來，l-i-h，i-h唸作i，l-i，裂，這個是動詞，也是單位，單位量詞，裂，一裂，它是第八調，裂，一裂
或是寫作裂開的裂，一裂，後面那個一裂，它是單位詞，前面是動詞，裂開的裂，就裂開一個縫，一裂
就像說，我的衣服，要，要，要崩，或是裂開了
那個褲腳，褲，褲，那個屁股處裂開了，就是裂開，裂開一個縫
再來，律師的律，u-t，ut，l-ut，lut，律師的律
再來，k-a，a-p，k-a-p，k-ap，蛤
這個蛤仔，這是蛤仔，蛤仔是什麼？青蛙
不要被華文誤導囉，這蛤，蛤仔是青蛙，又叫做四跤仔
你有聽過蛤仔嗎？蛤仔，不過他在講沒講，蛤仔就是青蛙，蛤仔、四跤仔都叫做青蛙
Frog，這個字是青蛙的意思
我剛才強調說不要被華文，不要被華文誤導囉，他要講蛤仔對嗎？
蛤仔的蛤
好，謝謝，好吧
蛤蜊，蛤蜊，我在那個，在嘴巴練習看一張像
一台貨車，他們在，他們在拍，做蛤蜊的，蛤蜊的廣告
他的車上面寫，掌聲蛤蜊蛤蜊
要包含喔，掌聲鼓勵鼓勵寫成掌聲蛤蜊蛤蜊
蛤蜊就是這個，蛤蜊，好，蛤蜊
啊，腳步是青蛙，腳步是青蛙
所以不要看到他這個，喔，你就說這是蛤蜊，不是喔，蛤蜊是這樣寫
這個蛤字，還有什麼？肉蛤，眼眶，肉蛤
好，這個蛤字，好
好，下面 KAT，KAT，割，啊，割
剛才講過喔，拍死割的割，再來 KAK，角，啊，角
角，那個，剛才有拍過嘛，還有一個八角喔，那也是有肉的，有肉的滷味，八角
再來 KAH，甲，啊，甲，甲，這個字呢，有幾個意思
一個是，我們一般知道，布袋，面，一個單位，一角兩角的角
好，再來，第二個，程度，程度副詞
我們說到那天，說，到，它是一個華語的「到」的意思
還有，我們說這個東西，要，好吃到，就，好吃到
好吃到難以形容，好吃到，這樣，就好吃到，到這麼，我們台語的到這麼
就是說，那個，那個程度你自己去體會，這樣說好吃到
前面，前面說，好吃到啦，跳到，喔，那有一首歌嘛，跳到，爽到，就是這個甲字
程度副詞，就是這個甲字喔，它這個字是，好吃到，它是雙連音，所以兩字連寫好吃到
它本調是甲，好，再來 KIP，急，喔，急，急促的急，這嘴唇要合喔
啊 P，再來，嘴唇要合，急，好，再來，急促的急，IG 唸做 IK，閣，伊，急，急促
好，那個急促，急促都在宜蘭比較多人，再來 IK 唸做 IK，閣，伊，極
好，革命，革命的極，好，再來 IH，伊，閣，伊，極
極，極，極，一九，閣，伊，極，極，IH 嘛，伊，伊，它不是 IK 喔，是 IH，閣，伊，極
七，這個字比較少看到喔，好，再來 UT，溫，閣，溫，棍，棍，棍頭的棍
好，再來，KH，科，科，啊，磕，磕頭，還有什麼？碰不到，碰不到
動不動就怎麼樣，磕袂著，這個磕字，磕袂著，動不動
動不動要怎樣怎樣怎樣，動不動到處跑，好，下面 AT，AT，科，啊，磕
動詞，咬，咬啦，華語的咬，好，名詞，跤落，勺子，較大的，湯勺的跤落
啊古早人都用那個瓢喔，瓢跤落，瓢跤落，好，這個跤字，舌頭的跤，好，腳頭的跤
好，再來 KHAK，AK，啊，科，啊，磕，帶殼，磕，什麼磕，後面 T 磕，什麼蝦殼的殼
好，再來 AH，啊，科，啊，較，這個就是，較怎樣，較，我較愛吃什麼，比較，比較怎麼樣
好，KIP 唸做 IP，科，伊，潗，剛才講過潗，噴水管的潗，噴水管的潗
好，再來 IT，IT，科，伊，乞，乞討的乞，乞討的乞，乞討的華語寫成乞丐
我們要寫哪一個字？乞食，乞士喔，這個乞食，乞食
所以呢，我們有時寫說去吃去吃，我們說乞食乞食，你罵我，喔，乞食
好，再來 IK，IK 唸做 IK，科，伊，隙，隙縫的隙
好，IH，伊，科，伊，缺，缺角，缺，我們說碗，碗有缺角喔，缺角，角它是寫成縫隙的隙
這個碗缺角，我們唸第二聲，第三聲缺角，缺，這個字是缺
就缺一個角，缺角，KHIH，缺角，碗缺一角喔，它也是單位詞，角
好，再來 UT，溫，KH，科，溫，睏，睡著，睡著，睏
好，知道，好，中場休息